buongiorno studenti oggi per puntata di
natale totò koné news.va esperimento
compiaccio se poteva dare rapida
dimostrazione di cosa ghiaccio secco ma
è a contatto con liquidi
[Musica]
in ambienti pulire l'ottone fatto casino
totò ripianato magia 3 questa essere
ghiaccio secco ghiaccio anche detto
chiaccio di natale giocatore passare a
esperimento sempre di buon natale amici
di totò
perché oggi sotto essere poco appare
ferimento natalizio puliti natale essere
esperimenti di oggi cosa essere poi la
di natale essere come quella di sapone
ma natalizia però pare bolle di natale
dottore necessitare di pochi pochi pochi
ingredienti ma necessari a rendere
ciotola inserire all'interno di ciotola
ingrediente impossibile da trovare in
casa essere acqua inserire l'acqua fino
quasi a bordo 18
una volta inserita acqua sotto 9 aprile
saponi per questa perderti bolle di
sapone sono fatte con benzina inserire
sapone all'interno di cucchiaio e di
inserire all'interno di miscuglio appena
creato con h2o mescolare ciotola lista
pollino che il natale non finire una
volta mescolato miscuglio totò rinsavire
anche glicerolo cucchiaino di glicerolo
due toghe non sapere neanche cosa essere
ma fa niente essere commestibile no
dottore numero 9 inserire e due a girare
di mischia
passiamo allo step successivo cioè
andare avanti sperimento due torri
dovevamo utilizzare due bottiglie dove
tagliare estremità di bottiglia e
inserire in alta bottiglia perché
contenitore generatore di bolle puoi
capire soltanto quando potrebbe fare
quindi cominciare totò riina viene
tagliere e totò riavere qui bello
spirito natalizio storno un po più piano
totò che tagliare prima bottiglia con
con cattiveria fra voi non dovevano
essere cattivi perché essere natale una
volta essere tagliato collo di bottiglia
vogliono in bottiglia piccolo andare
completamente rimosso e dove utilizzare
collo di bottiglia più grande che andare
a tagliare
adesso questo torre avere adesso
bottiglia più grande con collo più
grande è aver inserito il nuovo tappo di
bottiglia all'interno per poter generare
inserire tatto bucato sopra il collo di
bottiglia appena generato renderle tubo
di plastica e inserire all'interno di
book
proprio così infine dottore scocciare
tutto per evitare perdite di sapone
acqua e aria da bottiglie stappare bene
bottiglia con un nuovo tappo generato
con scotch ha appena strappato proprio
così prove avere saldato tappo di
bottiglia con l'appena generato visto
tutorial e ha creato arma
dell'istruzione peggio di saccà posti
benedetta
notoria abbiamo preso ultimo ingrediente
di esperimento che sarà il ghiaccio
secco ghiaccio secco essere molto
pericoloso utilizzare guanti per evitare
ingiurie quanto e sarà messo al
contrario si trova in mano a se stesso
nella sua vita
dottore essere finito prima ancora di
partire la torre essere adesso coperto e
protetto inserire un litro di acqua
all'interno due motivi è generata prima
proprio così dottore inserire nel suo
100 g di ghiaccio con la mano totale
paura
sto meno paura dottore temerario tutt
ora fare niente inserire ghiaccio secco
all'interno di acqua bottiglia fare
verso di gallina a ricordare l'episodio
tutt ora è spazientito basta dove
inserire tappo a parigi ratu modà turbo
totò e adesso prendere questo per
inserire all'interno e vedere che
generarsi cose incredibili trovi aver
generato balla totolare aveva generato
bolla di natale quanto essere bella
molla di natale sarà bianca come natale
tuttavia creato un sacco di bolle e
esperimento effettivamente funzionare ma
poter avere potere fare cose anche
carine ad esempio se dottore mettere una
specie di tappeti sapone bruciare tubo e
dottore fare rimanere bolle ferme essere
atomica aiuto dottori avere un po paura
quanto poter continuare questa cosa
folle ingrandirsi dottore creato sfera
agenti dama di goku store e continuo a
stare così natale essere attività un
altro potere staccare tutoria staccare
tutorial mercato bolla incredibile
scoppiare
sarà proprio un genio dottore adesso
farle seconda parte di esperimento con
ciò sarà molto più grande necessitare
sempre diario secco e l'ace di scarpa
tinto torre la cd scappa deve essere
scappa vecchia necessario prendere
sapone coprire bordo di bacinella con
sapone fatale inserire adesso ghiaccio
secco all'interno di bacinella e
generare un sacco di ma poi basta e
successiva dottore inserire lancio di
scarpa che aveva appena preso
all'interno di sapone proprio così e
inzuppare per bene perché la cd scappa
essere veramente necessario per nostro
esperimento tutorial sa tirare fuori la
ci scappa veramente inzuppato di noto
torre stava riuscendo per germania
mi butto torre amante del natale no sono
certo no
[Musica]
dottore avere creato polla tipacci nella
questo cosa volere dire volere dire che
adesso se il ghiaccio non stancato
perché gli essere se come pare generare
vapore dottore bederke crearsi bolla
incredibile e natale essere magico per
tutti pantin intimidatoria provare
adesso a scoppiare
l'incredibile potrebbe fatto veramente
bel video oggi mettere mi piace subito
videocrazia facendo uno di stoppate totò
l'inserviente totò ma e starebbe
progettando progetti temibile dal
prossimo mese perché totale lega funding
magazine cim panzini però è frenetico la
mente adesso matto prove essere presente
da gennaio i magazine pacchetto 89
diventare famoso
quindi vuoi trovare totò riina gennaio
come a casa in cima dottore rivedersi
con voi studenti 11 gennaio anno nuovo
buon natale a tutti però 11 gennaio
esserci prossime scadimento poi che fa
ben pubblicarle su playlist di
esperimento incredibile che trovate qui
oppure se aver visto tutti esperimenti 4
mar e di livello quindi micangeli lo sa
mai ha visto anche video bello qualche
noi incredibili allora a cliccare su
iscrizione canale che sarei qua perché
mancare solo quello
buone feste dubbi baciato top
[Musica]